if you live in negativity all day long
you're you're screwed you train people
how to work with you some clients won't
like that they miss allocate their time
and that's why they never scale
[Music]
[Applause]
I really like what you said about chunky
okay work with that quite a bit
do you have any other advice for how to
increase high quality output if you find
yourself getting distracted a lot or
getting unfocused it's usually because
either you don't like the thing that
you're doing or you're afraid of it
being released and so recognizing the
difference between the two and the plan
is always in action either you need to
figure out a way to get rid of some of
those things that you you don't like or
if you're afraid then you have to dive
into it so if you're like if you're how
long you've been sitting on your website
you know you're afraid of getting it out
there and so then it's another another
week and another weekend another month
another two months another six months
and it doesn't happen you're
procrastinating procrastination is
either you don't like it I need to get
rid of it as soon as possible and maybe
you let some small balls drop to focus
on the big ones that you care about or
procrastination is fear and you're
afraid of releasing something and being
judged for it in which case you have to
go off and attack it so you can be able
to break down why are you getting why
you getting I don't want to be
distracted right now I'm pissed like if
this thing actually went off I'd be so
upset at myself that I let that happen
right please nobody likes Emmie Nina's
gonna like send me a Facebook or
something yeah so being able to stay
focused having a morning routine that
sets you up everyday asking yourself are
you proud of the reasons why you didn't
follow through living in the state of
potential regret when when you need to I
don't think it's good to live in a state
of fear and pain and regret but you can
call on it to help you make the powerful
decisions when you need to like every
superhero has a dark side so it's if you
live in negativity all day long you're
you're screwed so you want to live in
the land of optimism and positivity and
achievement and the impact you're gonna
have but sometimes it's not enough
sometimes you're thinking about your
vision and that's not enough to motivate
you and so you have to remember your mom
who said you're not gonna make it or
your brother who said that book is never
gonna come out and you use that as that
as fuel as pain to help get you over the
hump
you just can't live there constantly if
you're constantly in a state of I'm
gonna show you you can't have that as
the foundation for your life I'm gonna
prove you wrong
you use it in acute moments to help you
get over hurdles and immediate pain but
acute moments only because you want to
be living in in positivity and optimism
for the most part that's how you like
the practical steps you train them you
train people how to teach how to work
with you you're teaching them so I like
running a no crisis business I want to
run a no crisis business and that means
I need to not work with some clients if
you need me to hold your hand and be
responsive 24/7 I'm not your guy but
when we're working together I'm gonna
crush it for you because I'm focused and
some people love that and some people
hate that
and so I lose those people same thing
for my team I had a guy on my team so
the way we communicate on my team usual
hangouts and Facebook is how I can
connect with my wife my parents any any
family or close friends stuff like your
on my Facebook have you been to my house
right as a friend and so I have to teach
everybody in that in those ecosystems to
like they know not to bug me so it's
urgent
then then message me otherwise email me
if it's within 24 hours email if you
need a response ASAP then message me and
we'll fix it but then we're gonna fix
the thing that caused that so that
doesn't happen again so today a new guy
my team who's helping do my Spanish
Channel we have a new Spanish channel
that we're trying to reach the Spanish
market with and we made a video on Dan
lock in Spanish just came out like today
and he messages me say hey can you send
this to Dan so he knows about the video
because maybe he'll promoted to his
audience to Spanish market I said don't
send me a hangout message hangout is
emergency only
I didn't he made some joke about it it's
like this is not a joke like you
disrespecting my time Hangouts his
emergency send me an email and he says
ok and then I sent them a heart right
and so he knows I really see better now
right because I'm to look at your
message it means it's urgent
that means you were actually pulling me
away from something because that is
actually open all day on my computer
in case something happens so you're
pulling me off of something even if it's
even if it's my relaxed time watching
League of Legends you're pulling me off
of that so it better be a virgin
emergency if it can hang me handle in 24
hours so I sort my email 24 hours my
team partners my prior to email folder I
respond within 24 hours and I have my
general email folder for everybody else
it's usually within 24 hours but who
knows what's happening but the people on
my team can expect the response within
24 hours something like that send this
add an LOC that's a 24 hour just to
respond you're not sending for a week
but it's okay Louis I get I know about
it in 24 hours it's not an urgent send
me a message on hangouts so just to that
I don't have a phone number I haven't
had a phone number for for 12 years
other people's agender for your time I
used to be a lot weirder than it is now
because getting connected now we can
still get connected on like data I have
data so we can do Instagram and respond
your DMS and on stuff but I don't wanna
be interrupted we don't have a home
phone either nobody can reach me and
when I was dating Nina she didn't like
it because she couldn't reach me but now
when we were together she likes it cuz
nobody can reach me so I'm intentional
like you're like here when I'm with you
I'm with you guys I'm not think of
anything else I want to help you guys
I'm not here drifting about something
else that's why I can't I get sick and
like it says it is a negative side to it
too because it's so focused on the thing
that I don't allow myself to get
distracted by anything else and being
willing to drop some small ball some
some clients won't like that your real
estate agent you got to be on 24/7 I
need somebody who like when there's a
deal they're gonna be there for me like
as you build your team that's their job
right so I want every comment on my
YouTube channel to get a response at the
beginning that was me because it's
getting two comments a day now we get I
don't know puns
puns and so it's somebody's full-time
job plus just responding to comments and
saving the ones that I need to see I
want to see all the negative ones like
hey when you suck because of this great
tell me why I suck oh yeah let's get
better
all the positive ones I thank you so
much for this video he'll respond and
put his name at the end so you need to
be responsive but that eventually
becomes your team and in the beginning
your genius is not going to be in being
the super responsive guy it's going to
be in the what you're great at so this
is where I think people spend the wrong
they miss allocate their time and that's
why they never scale so making youtube
videos people will make a 20 minute
YouTube video they'll spend 20 minutes
making a video and 4 hours at it in it
because you want to look professional
your ambition is not to be a great
editor it's to be a great presenter and
communicator you're training the wrong
skill you're spending too much time on
the wrong skill for hours editing 20
minutes should be flipped it spend 4
hours I didn't making a video so that
you can spit fire for 10 minutes
straight without making mistakes because
that skill will serve you for life and
20 minutes editing just throwing on a
quick intro extra now that means it
won't be as polished or fancy as all the
other videos you're seeing but its fire
content coming from you that's a skill
you want to train and get better that's
a skill that then allows you to go off
and hire an editor because you're making
money from it because people see the
videos they like you they're not going
to come to you because you have the
fancy music or you're driving up in the
Beamer or whatever else they're coming
to you for your knowledge and because I
think they like you and you can help
them so that's what's going to actually
get you to the editor that's what will
get me to add a me to edit my content
then it can blow up but most people
spend time training the wrong skill and
you spend so much time editing instead
of filming and then you never get to the
point where you skill your company
because you're spending all your time on
the thing that you suck at and you can
apply that to anything not just video
production are you spending the time on
the right skills so it's been a great
trip to Albuquerque one of the things
that really stood out from the event was
just how thankful people were that I
stopped in Albuquerque I think of all
the cities that I've been to this city
in particular people are said thank you
so much most people don't stop here most
people just fly over and head out to
Calif
we don't have a lot that happens here in
New Mexico in Albuquerque and we end up
having to travel to get to other places
and so we saw you were coming so we had
to come and that's a really warm amazing
vibe now a lot of people helped and
helped him promote the event I want to
give them a quick shout out
[Music]
and if you want to see what we do on our
next stop and Phoenix go check the like
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there